Jacqueline for your work on the revenant
whose costume did you work on first
Lea's definitely and what was the the
reason because you felt to Center I
think it was important to figure out his
character and what he would wear and to
tell the story of his character
especially for alejandro he's the
pivotal point of the story of course
it's the story of Hugh glass and I felt
that if I had his look established and
the feeling for it and the emotion of
that costume that that costume would
evoke it would kind of determine the
people around him because I felt he was
it quite a different character than the
other trappers for the most part he
wasn't a trapper he trapped for food and
survival but he was looking for
something much different out in the
wilderness than the other trappers he it
was more of a spiritual quest for him he
had lived with the Native Americans he
communed with the animals it was a kind
of commonality between Leo and in nature
that he and the animals were in it
together surviving in this very very
extreme environment and they used each
other or fought each other or did
whatever and I thought that all had to
be embodied in his costume and I knew he
was the most important character
spiritually for Alejandro who's a
metaphorical director so early on i
showed alejandro two pictures one was
Anna Rick hora hunter not a not a
warrior a hunter he
in a long knee length fur leather coat
with a hood and he was very monk-like
and Alejandro really responded to that
it was and then I showed him a Russian
icon of a Russian monk in the early
1800s and Leos costume started evolving
from those two pictures do you remember
when he first tried on that the coat
that this monk like very well Alejandra
was there in the room and I had my
cutter fitter Rosalie Lee who's
brilliant in the room and he put it on
and he just he already had his beard and
he put her on and he looked like a
mystic almost and I knew Alejandro would
respond I had three versions but there
was one version when I took a picture of
him he was almost Jesus like it looked
like a Russian icon his eyes just lit up
the room and all this beard and the fur
of the hood and the leather and I I saw
Leo's whole body language changing he
went from modern to mountain man in
about five minutes it was amazing it was
an amazing transformation and when we
took fitting pictures of him in that
room and the light was coming in it was
we were in Calgary and the light off the
Rockies was it was all one side of the
room was glass and it was just shining
in on him and it was like he was in this
like a beam of light like from heaven
and he just lit up and it was quite an
amazing moment I'll never forget it so
how did that one costume impact the rest
of the work for the revenant I thought
it was important for him to look like a
guide somebody who hunted to keep the
men alive and a leader so
leo has power and stature just by his
size he's tall he's got great big broad
shoulders but he also i felt shouldn't
look like quite the mercenary as i made
tom hardy this costume to reflect it he
Tom Hardy was there not just for
survival but for monetary gain he was in
the wilderness for completely different
reasons than you glass so I wanted his
coat to look a little bit more designed
I used fringe to with the water is
totally lined in pelts his hat his at
the beginning the movie he were wears a
piece called an eye patch to cover his
scar because it was historical that when
anyone was scalped that was a more
seasoned fur trader they were told to
cover their scars so that the young it
wouldn't scare the young recruits to the
fur trade off so it gave him almost kind
of pirate sinister look at the beginning
later on I added more and more badger as
he goes towards the fort he's got a full
on a badger down his back otter down his
back and Badgers on the front and I
figured those two animals have totally
figured out the wilderness and survival
and they're very wily and smart and
there was a certain because he's not a
black or white characters so they're in
the greys doing he's a victim of his own
desire to survive and it goes awry and
it's an intentional for some part and
the other party's just mean but I wanted
that survival of the fittest in his
incorporated into his coat and then
Bridger was young Jim Bridger how it was
reflected in his
wardrobe he's in the movie a lot he was
became having been trained by Hugh glass
about the wilderness he became the most
famous mountain man of all times there's
a fort erected to him in Montana Jim
Bridger became the definitive mountain
man in America and probably he's the
most famous he's the one although
reenactment people emulate so I made his
coat Buffalo to represent the Great
Plains and having been trained about the
Great Plains by Hugh glass I lined it
it's uh it's it's a real buffalo skin
turned inside out because I thought that
showed you know a certain smartness
wearing the fur on the inside and that
was that was the theory behind him and
then Captain Henry I tried to keep out
of fur as much as they could and keep
his military bearing intact and
fortunately I kind of pounced on the
Museum of the fur trade which this
lovely woman Gail Potter who have known
for several years runs and curates and
she helped me a lot she had a lot of
actual pieces under glass of Henry's
clothing with drawings other men had
done of Captain Henry so she had his
actual leggings leather leggings there
at the Museum of the fridge raid in Chad
noon Chadron Nebraska and she let me
copy them and they're under glass
they're from 1823 is the way you begin a
film the same for every project or does
each one have its own specific course of
research hmm that's a good that's a good
question basically basically the same I
start by really just immersing myself in
the period I read novels written in the
period I read journals I read letters I
read and if it's a historical character
like Hugh glass who was close to my
heart because we have a ranch and
Dakota about a hundred miles from the
mouth of the Grand River where this bear
attack took place and as we've traveled
through South Dakota with our horses to
ride in different areas we passed the
mile markers Hugh glass spent his 40th
night crawling to Fort Kiowa here this
is where Hugh glass climbed into a horse
this is where it you know he's this
historic icon he's one of he's also one
of the famous mountain mens in South
Dakota there's statues erected to him
and mile markers and so I read every
biography I could find about Hugh glass
I started reading fur trapping journals
Gail Potter the museum of the fur trade
gave me some fabulous books like 40 Jack
Fisk gave me 40 years of fur trapper she
gave me the historic history of the
textiles and furs and and wolves of the
fur trade I just read everything then I
look at pictures like lib by night which
I'm working on right now with Ben
Affleck is a totally different process
because the 20s was so and the 30s are
so photographed by some of my favorite
favorite photographers so that was a
different process this film the revenant
was much more based on paintings
drawings and accounts a lot of diaries
journals written accounts and when you
when I did all that on this on the
revenant then it had to all be filtered
through Alejandro's vision and as I said
he's very metaphorical and so it he
didn't care so much about me being a
stickler for the exact history or the
exact he wanted each costume to create
an emotion and I can tell if I've hit it
or not without
andhra by his body language he responds
so viscerally to things that he you need
to create a mood that tells the
philosophy of that character where he
came from where he's going would his
full of own personal philosophy is and
how it's changed because of what's
happened to him it's the environment
he's been living in the minis been
surrounded with the animals he's had to
kill the indians said to kill and all of
that has to be incorporated into a
costume for alejandro for him to love it
and then the aging became something that
was the most important to him and to
chivo and that was something i had a
brilliant ager on this film that came up
with a solution to it because i had read
and told alejandro that when these
trappers got off the boats in in
missouri their clothes were so greasy no
one could tell what they were made of
were they wool with a leather or were
they for and so we came up with a
greasing process that the reason they
used bear grease and animal grease to
coat all their clothes and get that
really dirty aged patina was to keep
them dry it waterproof them there was no
they weren't it was no belstaff or
barber or north face or Patagonia then
so keeping warm was part of the whole
science of being fur trapper and I had
to make sure that was incorporated into
their wardrobe for the reality because
they spent so much time in below zero
temperatures and in the water freezing
water and I understand you do a back
story maybe of every character I do i
create you know and of course rent would
run these back stories by alejandro when
i send him pictures late of not at night
when he was done you know pre shooting
and rehearsing and everything is our
communication
we're going very very late I do drawings
and send him actually pictures of
prototypes that even dress people in the
costumes age them and then talk to him
about the backstory and on this movie it
had a lot to I had to create back
stories because they couldn't all be
cookie cutter trappers he would never be
able to have lived with that that he
hates anything that's cliche or you know
Daniel Boone s core Davy Crockett ask
you know for Coonskin caps were not
going to make it into this film and so
it became quite up and a process it was
I can only say it was a process I'd
create a backstory if there was anything
I read about all the men on the actual
Ashley expedition and I just pulled made
up kind of different tales for each of
these men like what part of the what
part of the country they came from what
their economic status was would they
have how long had they been in the
wilderness by their age how much of the
European wardrobe would have been copied
by Native women and turned into actual
leather and fur clothing to what extent
is the changeover how much will did they
both still have and that's was a big
part of the process now I understand you
started out as a designer in Berkeley
when you first began you know going into
film how ambitious were you to have that
as your full-time career or was it just
one project that led to the next I
wasn't at all in fact I was a fashion
designer and I had a successful company
with my own Department in Barney's in
New York and a very close friend of mine
was a filmmaker and asked me if I would
come and design the movie Henry in June
and it was Phil Kaufman who did the
right stuff and variable lightness to be
and he couldn't get me in the Union and
I was opening a new store in San
Francisco and I was my business was
really you know very big at that time
and I I said I couldn't and I was in
Paris showing my line at the pred aparte
and I get a call at my hotel that night
from his off-field Hoffman's office in
San Francisco asking if I would get in
touch with him and I called his hotel
actually was living on the plas devotion
Paris and I went and had dinner with him
and his wife and he said will you come
and work on this with me and I said well
he said we'll fly you back and forth to
Berkeley and I said sure because he'd
been to my house I wanted to introduce
him to walking in on it Easton's brother
who taught at Berkeley and I knew before
their movie started and he'd been to
dinner my house and said he wanted on a
stands house to look like my house and
he hadn't gotten that from the French
you know production design department
would I come and work on the movie and
design her house for him and so my first
credit was overall artistic consultant
to the director and on Henry in June and
I started buying things wildly it the
marche malik in paris for him and even
closed for the closets and stuff which
the actresses even ended up wearing and
so i wouldn't let him pay me for that
and so the very next movie he's my
friend and i stayed maybe a month in
paris working on it and I stood went
home and continued to send him drawings
of her house and colors for the rooms
and everything in the next movie he did
he said I want you to design it and
between Phil and sean connery they got
me in the Union and that and I was only
going to work for him ever and the
second movie I did with him i was
nominated which was quills and i started
getting all these calls from agents and
other directors and I gradually segue
from fashion into this business I
started doing more movies
you know creating my line fewer times a
year until I finally just left that
business and ended up here and came from
the Bay Area to Los Angeles mm-hmm I
didn't for a long time oh I worked from
there for a very long time how much
detail do you pay toward background
players solos oh the most interesting
the most because I feel that so much
attention anybody can get the three or
four lead characters right because you
spend so much time on them and and I
feel that it's the background that and
the background the cars the horses or
whatever carriages that really sell the
period it's that big background out
there if it looks really really real
then you have your you have the setting
the whole backdrop for the painting that
you're going to do your main portraits
within and I always say that the
background is the most important part of
the movie to me getting it right like
all the natives in this movie all the
background French trappers all the
trappers that don't have speaking roles
in the movie that are stuntman or just
part of the camp or part of the
entourage of trappers I think that's
what really really sells the close-ups
of your main cast when you begin a
production how many times do you read
the script and well I go by the day
Edith Head rule seven times before you
start don't even make one costume or do
one drawing two you've read the script
seven times because she said then you
know all your characters inside out and
you just take them shopping in the
period interesting and I understand that
sometimes you'll have it correct me
please if I'm if I'm mistaken here but a
number of outfits and you have that
character walk in and kind of choose in
Miami know it what should I thought I
forgive me okay well
redo that one I don't know why I thought
I had where that what eras do you find I
like to choose oh you like to choose I'm
sorry I first a reason is my Brad calls
me a method costume designer he said
that I get right down into the very
center I peel all those layers of the
onion away and dress actors from the
inside out and I try to do my homework
to such an extent that i have a favorite
costume going in that i've already shown
to the director and usually have gotten
you know a good response or you know
done my selling job there and i give
them choices of course because sometimes
they've been working on the role a long
time before they get to me often
especially really serious actors and
when they put something on that i am
rather keen on and the director is liked
when he's seen the pictures of the
research and they don't stand a certain
way or get that right body language i am
the first one to throw it away i have no
ego investment in a costume even when
it's a kind of favor of mine if you
don't if it doesn't work on them on
their bodies and you know good actors
you know when you hit the right costume
because of their body language it
changes totally changes its I've always
said that the costume is the bridge from
the actor to the character that's the
first time they start really feeling
that characters when they put on the
costume can you give me some physical
examples of the body language I mean do
their palms open up or they'll one my
favorite of all times is Geoffrey Rush
In quills and going to back to one of my
first movies but it happens almost on
every movie but it was so extreme with
Jeffrey when I put the Marquis de Sade
because he's very languid and loosened
and he's fluid and and you know I not
sloppy in his body movements but very
you know like his body has no bones in
it and when he put on the Marquis de
Sade's costume the white costume that he
wears for 25 years in prison his whole
body language changed he looked like an
aristocrat from a ocn painting and he
started walking differently and the
actor that he is he had me make one just
for him to wear for the two weeks before
he started shooting while he came to
England just to rehearse he worked day
and night he'd come when we were
shooting the lunatic asylum it was was
to be Charenton at at Luton who he
walked would walk around the grounds all
the all the very you know sculptured
palatial grounds of Luton who in that
costume you'd see him out in the shadows
in the hedgerows and stuff walking
around in the marquis de sade costume
with the little stacked heels and he he
would be so different then without it
for a budding costume designer you say
read and go to museums why and I just
think I don't even think it's more
museums it's everything just expose
yourself as much as you can to
literature and to art you know watch
every old movie that is considered like
a film classic read all the Russians
read all the American great American
literature read you know modern
literature and you know if I'd say every
young girl should read all the diaries
of Anais Nin to learn about character
and character studies read all ad eh
Lawrence look at all of every big
photographer from the beginning of
photography forward you know it's your
sentimental education you owe it to
yourself and the more you the smarter
you are and the
you've learned and the more you've
educated yourself and been educated by
others the better designer you'll be
because you'll have much more to call on
you'll have a better you know it's all
about background knowledge which is with
the internet now it's not considered as
important but it's what I've I stressed
to my daughter why she was growing up
she used to call me Miss trivia and I
said I said and you have to be to it's
all about background knowledge one
costume that stayed in your mind forever
from a film that it actually wasn't your
design but you never forgot it and you
always sort of reference back to it hmm
I don't even know if I have one it had
to I think it was a Casanova fellini's
Casanova it was one of Katherine ovis
costumes and and I actually emulated it
for the Marquis de Sade in quills
because I loved it so much and it was
Donald Sutherland in a corset and a
banyan what was it about that outfit
that just really said everything about
the character the riches of the fabric
in the Banyan and the idea of a man
wearing a corset being you know one of
the great lovers of all times and all
the ambiguity that that costume created
in that film I never have forgotten it